we're not different than anybody else
with a computer our mental handicap
would you please consider our four guys
in Rockville in Finland there's a punk
band that marches to the beat of its own
riot where we again are we allow our red
sticker economy Thai Baht has been
around the band for over eight years and
in 2016
these rock stars decided this will be
their last year performing together this
is their story
Vega kaaya Sharma's - ketta Raya drone
Rider
he liked the drums and the bass player
were from Helsinki Finland we start a
flip off hospital bed for one of the
punk rock band yet but we must respond
to groups performing of prompt and ok of
rest is history I can say we love hot
lead with the lower back with a rock on
and have a good time so early personal
or watch shows departures from about
that delicious to the phone let's use
Excel disclosed
the stage is like a workplace everything
is fine when we were on the page there
evidently having a good time for there
or that kind of the pit stop we don't
have a github we're for middle-aged guys
who love to rock'n'roll we agree with
grease p.m. we have Carly I love a good
cigar sometimes yeah
and press duplicate you just been
playing the walk a lot of the years
music Ramsey just wanted to do something
else that was that that was the whole
idea
are we respecting that so 26th of
December is our last big trip ever
and then this 73 we're little sad about
it but what's better what is much
[Music]